từ bắt phở ra chuyển bắt dời, biết tiếp cầu truyện ẩm thực hà thành của cacola Food Mask, quán định trận hành,
là một nền tảng giúp quảng má các hạn quán nầm thực đường phố tệ Việt Nam của tương hiệu của cacola
khi chung giúp tự hạn nội của cacola Food Mask không thể bọ qua phở bò,
mà có sự hẹn hôm nay là về phở thiền và o.
Năm trong con hẹn nhỏ, sống một định trên hoang, đối diện hồ hương phở thiền và o đã tổn tại được hơi bệnh Việt Nam
là để chỉ quán thuộc của điều thế hệ người hạn nội.
Cộng bộ chỉ thiền người sẵn lập quán tự những năm 1970 đã đưa hệnh phở giống thành tương hiệu quán thuộc với hương vị thành cạnh đặc trưng.
Nước dùng trong Thịt Bảo Mềm Ngọt và mùi thơm của hành gương đã tạo nên nét dường cho bắt phở nơi đây.
Không chỉ mang đã chiếm ẩm thực, phở thiên bơ hồ có lưu chứ kỳ hợp về hạn nội xưa.
Cộ thiền với chất áp lưu chẳng từ nơi hỏi vui là bắt si thiền, mời bắt phở của ông như bị tốt sở những ngày khó khăn.
Đối nay, tế hệ thứ 3 của gia đình vẫn tiếp nối ngọt lửa đảm về ấy, vui chỉ chất lợp qua tường là thiền, mắt nước dùng với tất cả mươi liệu được trọng lợp tìm mi.
Anh buổi chỉ thành, cháu nộ của thiền không chỉ giữ gì công thức chuyển thống mà còn làm mới hình ngày quán để thủ hút dưới chẻ.
Vở thiên bơ hồ không chỉ là món ăn mà còn là câu chuyện về dính dung nghe mà bắt mạa ập thủ.
Đồng viên dành trong rằng xác quán định món ngon của cuộc ca của la của Mác, quán tiếp tục là biểu cậu của sự rao thu ra, rớ chuyển thống và hiện nay,
bó phần lần của bạn bản sắc ở tục biệt nào giảnh hươi.